as millions more go unemployed ALC
proposes a work strike in Andrew Cuomo
proposes that people get jobs in
essential industries we learned that the
first American death could have been
weeks earlier than previously supposed
and president Trump undercuts George's
Governor on reopening i'm ben shapiro
this is de Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressive
VPN protect your data from prying eyes
and expressive VPN calm slash man that's
expressvpn calm slash man now you may
have noticed the economy is a trashy
right now and you may have also noticed
that the government is spending rules
and rules and rules of dollars which
means that now would not be a bad time
to get into precious metals market and
the fact is the stock market's gonna be
up it's going to be down but one thing
you know is that the government is never
going to pay off this debt which means
that having diversified into precious
metals probably a pretty smart idea
would've been smart to do that months
ago
it's still smart to do it now you should
go talk to my friends over at Birch gold
if you're interested in at least putting
some of your money in precious metals to
protect against inflation and future
risk and uncertainty over 22 million
people have lost their jobs are now up
to 26 million people as of today from
the economic fallout of coronavirus we
don't know long-term impact of this many
workers being displaced at once again
diversifying into precious metals is not
a bad idea before May 31st with a
qualifying purchase Birch gold will
actually give you a free emergency kit -
which is kind of a fun giveaway the
backpack is absolutely loaded with the
things you can't buy right now so
safeguard your savings with Birch gold
and they will help safeguard your family
the same way they have mine and so many
others there's no obligation you have
nothing to lose to take that first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau do not wait until the
market drops more to protect your
hard-earned savings get your free
emergency kit today text my name Ben -
47 47 47 and diversify into precious
metals today again text Ben - 47 47 47 X
Ben - 47 47 47 okay so the continuing
debate in American society is how
whether - what we were going to do to
reopen because the fact is that the
economic fallout from coronavirus is
absolutely devastating there's a new
report out today 4.4 million more
workers have now filed for unemployment
so we are now up to 27 million workers
in the past month and a half 5 weeks
filing for unemployment the relentless
increase in the jobless has intensified
the debate over when to lift
restrictions according to the New York
Times state agencies are scrambling to
handle the overwhelming flood of filings
as well as as well as set a set of
federal eligibility rules instituted to
deal with the crisis a lot of these
offices are understaffed in a survey the
Pew Research Center released on Tuesday
52 percent of low-income households
below $37,500 a year for a family of
three said someone in the household
lost a job because of koruna virus
compared with 32% of upper income
families that's people who earn over a
hundred and twelve thousand six hundred
dollars forty-two percent of families in
the middle have been affected as well
people without a college education have
taken that disproportionate hit as have
black and hispanic americans so for all
the talk about how the people who are
calling for reopening are out of touch
with the common man it's the people who
are not calling for a reopening who are
out of touch with the common man right
there they're out of touch with people
who are actually losing their jobs very
easy for people on CNN to sit there and
militate against people going back to
work or being allowed by the government
to go back to work a lot more difficult
when you actually have to go back to
work to go out there and feed your
family and support your family if you
want to determine who is out of touch
determine who has a job who's currently
calling for everybody else not to be
able to go back and get a job now I want
to get into the the business side of
this the economic side the the shutdown
side of this in just one second first we
have to bring you the statistical
updates there are a couple of pieces of
news that are somewhat interesting first
of all we now know the corona virus was
spreading fairly widely in the United
States well before anyone really
suspected that it was according to the
New York Times by the time that New York
City confirmed its first case of korone
virus on March 1st
thousands of infections were already
silently spreading through the city a
hidden explosion of a disease many still
viewed as a remote threat as the city
awaited the first signs of spring hidden
outbreaks were also spreading almost
completely undetected in Boston San
Francisco Chicago and Seattle long
before testing showed that each city had
a major problem according to a model of
the spread of the disease by researchers
at Northeastern University even in early
february while the world is focused on
china the virus is not only spreading in
multiple american cities it was seeing
blooms of infection elsewhere in the
United States in five major US cities as
of March 1st there were only 23
confirmed cases of corona virus but
according to the northeastern model
there actually could have been about
28,000 infections in those cities by
that now that's bad news because it
means that we didn't detect this thing
as quickly as we should it is good news
in the sense that a lot more people have
had this thing then we already thought
and didn't even know it at the time
right antibody tests continue to show
that a huge number of people who never
were diagnosed with corona virus have
already had corona virus in the first
place which means that the case fatality
rate of this thing is again way lower
than we have been led to believe it is
probably in my opinion somewhere between
point 2 and point 6 percent it is not 3
percent it is not 4 percent it is
13% or 11% right now in New York City if
you just look at the number of deaths
over the number of diagnosed cases
you're looking at something like 10% or
11% if you look at the actual number of
cases that have happened right
asymptomatic cases cases where people
have antibodies but never we're actually
diagnosed with coronal virus in the
first place every single study done
shows a high multiple of that in terms
of the number of people who actually had
this thing right and we're asymptomatic
now the bad news about that is that
asymptomatic people are the ones who are
most infecting people because you're
going around you don't know that you
have a problem and you are infecting
everybody else around you
this makes testing regimes particularly
in high population areas like New York
extremely vital right this is why when
when people talk about testing testing
is designed to prevent the hot spots
from flaring up I've pointed this out
many many times flattening the curve is
designs prevent overwhelming the
healthcare system testing is basically a
variation of that testing widespread
testing is not designed to prevent
everybody from getting the disease the
general idea is that over time many
people who get the disease we're
basically buying time for people to come
up with therapeutics is really what we
are doing here two things to build up
medical capacity and buy time to come up
with drugs that actually work better
against coronavirus those are the two
things that we are doing right now and
testing regimens basically allow us to
identify when a hotspot has emerged and
then contact trace those hotspots but
the idea that we are going to be able to
fully go back to American industry or
that even with the lockdowns lift that
we are going to see a v-shaped recovery
that people are just gonna go back to
bars people are gonna go out to night
clubs looking to go back to their normal
lives it's just not true
it's just not true now again it is
important to recognize the differences
in population here
the Fox News has a has an analysis of
the people who have died in New York
City and here's what then and they're
quoting a study from the Journal of
American Medical Association JAMA which
is sort of the industry standard a new
study by a medical journal revealed that
most of the people in New York City who
are hospitalized due to coronavirus had
one or more underlying health issues
health records from 5700 patients
hospitalized with in the northwell
health system which housed the most
patients in the country throughout the
pandemic show that 94% of patients had
more than one disease other than coded
19 according to JAMA data taken from
March to early April show that the
median age of patients was 63 years old
and 53% of all coronavirus patients
suffered from hypertension the most
prevalent of the ailments among
now I've talked to dr. Marty mikaze from
Johns Hopkins and he suggests that
hypertension doesn't exist alone that
usually when somebody has hypertension
that person also has the second
condition and the second condition is
really the one that's a problem not the
hypertension so obesity is a condition
that is very that has great overlap with
with hypertension diabetes has great
overlap with hypertension 42% of corno
virus patients had body mass index data
on file suffered from obesity 32% of all
patients suffered from diabetes data
gathered from 2600 patients who either
died or were discharged from the
hospital showed 12% replaced on
ventilators and of those who were 88% of
them died so for all the focus on
ventilators if you were put on a
ventilator basically your odds of
getting out of the hospital
we're about 10 percent 12 percent which
is really bad odds rate so when we were
talking about ventilators we were
talking about significant but marginal
increases in life possibility but once
you hit events later you were in very
very serious trouble we also now know
that coronavirus deaths in the United
States are largely happening at nursing
homes according to The Wall Street
Journal the number of u.s. coronavirus
wind deaths in long-term care facilities
including nursing homes has clip 10,000
as nursing home owners said they are
struggling to access the testing they
need to detect and curb outbreaks a
growing number of state health
departments are reporting data including
fatalities linked to facilities that
primarily house older people who are
often in frail health and particularly
vulnerable to infection from the new
corona virus some states still have not
actually reported data on deaths in such
facilities but it seems like these
places are the death traps for
coronavirus which makes perfect sense
you have a bunch of people who are very
vulnerable in a closed space not going
out into open air very often and
breathing all over each other because
it's an enclosed space hey one thing
that summer in spring should do and this
is why it's so idiotic for governments
to shut down parks it relieves moronic
as long as people are socially
distancing parks are the best place in
the world for people to be people being
inside small crowded areas is the worst
place for people to be I mean this is
what happened with Chris Cuomo and Chris
Cuomo at CNN he had coronavirus he
infected his wife he infected his 14
year old son that's not his fault I mean
is in a house right here in a house with
your family but the vast majority of
coronavirus infections that are
happening at least according to Chinese
studies are happening in small enclosed
areas and largely their familial
transmission as somebody in the house
gets it and then everybody in the house
gets it which is one of the reasons that
you know I a personal level on a very
personal level it's one of the reasons I
concerned because my parents are 64 and
they're over at our house a lot helping
to take care of the kids we've locked
down we have a very close circle but
it's one of the reasons why I would be
more careful than if my parents were not
over here right I'm not really that
worried about infecting my life or
infecting my kids we're all young and
healthy thank God but my parents even
though they are healthy are 64 years old
right so I would be concerned about
their health and so people who are who
are surrounding themselves with people
in a vulnerable population obviously
have to be more careful so where do we
go next in terms of the in terms of the
modeling this is one of the big
questions I asked yesterday what if
nothing changes what if there are no
real therapeutic cures that come about
in the next two months that really
changed the game the vaccine is at least
a year away we say 12 to 18 months away
and what if nothing big hat what if the
summer doesn't kill off coronavirus what
if basically this is what it is right I
mean what we are experiencing now is
what it is what sort of precautions can
we take what sort of people should be
going back to work and yes it is vital
to go back to work because if nothing
changes if this is the new status quo
we're gonna have to figure out how to
work within this status quo because what
is happening right now is completely
unsustainable and as we'll see when we
talk about reopening this thing when you
hear from politicians things like well
if you just save one life that is the
left that argument is the last refuge of
the political scoundrel single factor
analysis is the enemy of good sense
single factor analysis is the enemy of
good sense if all you are saying is if
we save one life that makes for the
worst public policy in the entire world
because if you just save one life is a
policy that leads you to get rid of it
is the policy that leads you to get rid
of cars it's the policy that leads you
to never go out from your house if you
just save one life is not the only
question here there's also the question
of quality of life of freedom of
relationships of how you live your life
I mean it seems to me that there are two
very serious questions one is death
obviously but the other is quality of
life which makes a difference to people
who are alive which is going to be the
vast majority of people we even get
kovat 19 the vast majority people get
coma 19 are gonna live what is quality
of life like for the 329 million people
who are not going to die of kovaydin 19
right I was 330 million people 320 9.5
million people are not gonna die of
Kovan 19 in the United States quality of
life for those people matters and I'm
not talking about marginal changes in
quality of life we're talking about
people losing their life savings people
losing their possibility of income
people who are now reliant on the
government reliant on food stamps we're
about blowing out the debt for future
generation so that people will never be
able to recover in the United States so
the United States basically becomes a
state-run system these are serious
serious questions and to pretend that
the only consideration for the midterm
is is just how many lives you save in
the short term that doesn't even take
into account what happens during a
second wave especially if the lockdowns
are not actually saving lives remember
the purpose of the lockdown is not to
exceed the capacity of the health care
system so once we have built up the ICU
beds and built up the ventilators I'm
not sure what else you can do other than
putting in place testing regimens that
allow you to identify the hotspots and
prevents a spike above medical capacity
and and what and and making moves to
protect nursing homes for example other
than that there's not all that much you
can do now that doesn't mean that we're
gonna have that big booming recovery
coming right out of this because all
evidence suggests not but let's look at
the forecast as to what could
theoretically happen in terms of
coronavirus that so there are five
different forecasts that have been put
out by a variety of models the Imperial
College model suggests that we are just
basically going to continue to rise
right the Imperial College model says
that we're going to continue to rise in
terms of deaths because people are going
to leave their houses people are going
to infect each other and it's gonna
continue to to move through the
population and kill people and then
there's the MIT model which suggests
that it's going to tail off to the point
where we are experience about a thousand
deaths a day the ia the IHM II model the
one that's been widely ripped which is
now projecting 66,000 deaths in the
United States by August first that model
basically suggests we're gonna be down
to basically zero deaths a day by August
first that seems very optimistic to me I
mean given given what we know that seems
like a very optimistic model that's
that's the one people have been citing
there's a Columbia model that suggests
that by August 1st we're still gonna be
having just under a thousand deaths a
day according to the New York Times most
of the models shown above predict that
the country is currently past or near
the peak of number of deaths for this
wave of the epidemic but they estimate a
range of total deaths from 60,000 to
100,000 through May 23rd the models use
different techniques to project the
future
most of them share an important basic
assumption they're all built around the
notion the current regimen of stay at
home orders in social distancing will
continue almost all of them cut off
their predictions after two months or
less even though epidemiologists believe
the corona virus pandemic will be with
us for far longer this is one of the
problems with models is that these
models are assuming that we all stay
home forever which obviously is
unsustainable it is something that
cannot happen and so what you really
need to see is what the models say about
things that are not complete lockdown
orders what's in the model say about the
mid-range solution right young healthy
people going back to work wearing masks
and socially distancing right that's
what you need to see you don't need the
model that says what if we go out and
swap spit with each other in public
places and you don't need the model that
says what if we just lockdown for the
rest of time because neither of those
two things is gonna happen what you need
is what do the models say about a
variety of public policies in the middle
and those are the models that are not
really being presented to the public
according to the New York Times
Reacher's our researchers still aren't
sure the rate at which people who become
infected die or the rate of transmission
to other people which are like the two
key stats right that would be the
infection rate the replication rate of
the virus and it would be the case
fatality rate which I've been talking
about so the only two stats that matter
researchers still don't know the answer
to this is why those antibody tests
matter so we can at least establish the
baseline case fatality rate they suspect
the infection rate is really high I also
suspect the infection rate is incredibly
high like three so if I were just gonna
Ballpark this thing you a best available
scenario to me if there were no
lockdowns right now right no social
distancing no lock downs I think that
you'd probably be looking about half a
million dead over the course of the year
the reason I say that is because you are
you're looking at the flu killing maybe
50,000 people a year the flu it has a
point one percent death rate it also
does not infect as much of the popula
it's about it has a replication rate of
just over one the flu the the
replication rate for coronavirus is
about three so it's about three times as
infectious and it's about three times as
deadly so that means that using those
factors this thing is about will kill
about nine times as many people as the
flu would in a given year so you're
looking at about anywhere from four
hundred five hundred thousand deaths if
this were left unchecked now with social
distancing and with the hand-washing and
people not touching their faces you hope
that that cuts that down pretty
significantly but but you are going to
end up in six figures of death for the
year there's just no question you'll end
up in six figures for death for
coronavirus over the course of the year
I would be I'd be willing but a
significant sum of money considering
that we already have almost 50,000
deaths in the United States in the past
five weeks I think you're looking at
more than that now that is not a looking
at that in isolation does not answer the
question as to how we go back to work
because again
we do have to go back to work there are
countervailing their account surveilling
concerns here and even keeping people at
home indefinitely
is not going to kill the the virus
itself right we are going to leave our
houses at some point we cannot live like
this forever
several epidemiologists say it's hard to
expect the models to offer precise
forecasts at this point because they're
relying on uncertain inputs again the
Imperial College model was suggesting
that we are going to get up to four
thousand deaths a day in the near future
so like thirty five hundred deaths a day
the Columbia model was suggesting that
we were going to get about 2,000 deaths
a day sorry that's the the eye hme model
the columbia model was suggesting that
we were gonna get just under two
thousand deaths a day so all these
models are incredibly variable but when
people suggest that the models were just
plain wrong that that really is not
quite true it really is not quite true I
mean that the models are not exact but
the models are not dead wrong because
the eye hme model the one that was
widely cited and I've said changed over
time was a curve fitting model it's
taking new information in and then it's
providing you with a better curve right
now their estimate of 67,000 deaths
looks optimistic by August first okay so
what exactly are we doing to reopen and
how seriously should we take reopening
I'll tell you what is what is incredibly
stupid
what is incredibly stupid is some of the
things people are saying about reopening
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that there has never been a better time
to do education online like now would be
the time to do education online you
literally cannot go to a college campus
right now anyway this is why I recommend
Ashford University Ashford University's
online bachelor's and master's degree
programs allow you to learn on a
convenient schedule that works for you
right now you need to make yourself more
employable there are tons of people are
out of work
getting a new skill set that allows you
to be more attractive to employers is
gonna be a huge thing when we come out
of this pandemic even if it is a Nike
swoosh shaped recovery you can pursue a
degree to help you have a brighter
future in one of Ashford 60-plus
programs like Business Administration
health care administration and
psychology with 24/7 access to your
class from daily support and financial
aid available Ashford will give you the
tools you need to keep climbing you're
made for moments like these because you
are hashtag tenacity made just like
Ashford these are tough times now's the
time for you to really boost that resume
education is personal at Ashford your
success is their success there's no fee
to apply or standardized testing
required to enroll go do it today go to
Ashford
edu slash button that is Ashford edu
slash Ben Ashford II D u slash Ben not
all programs available in all states go
check them out right now okay so how
exactly are these are people going to go
back to work how exactly is this
transition back to normal life going to
happen well New York City is trying to
prep for large-scale testing programs to
combat the corona virus and spread that
obviously is really really necessary in
New York and it's gonna have to be a
massive testing regimen because it's
gonna have to almost be block by block
the place is just so populous that if
you have a hotspot that thing can spread
almost immediately
you've got public transportation
honestly I think there's a good case to
be made that they should shut down the
subway system
and they should have shut down the
subway system months ago and tell people
to ride bicycles like ride bicycles
walk work from home and if it takes
longer to get to work employers should
be a little more flexible about that
putting people in small bullet shaped
containers with no open air in the
middle of a pandemic seems like pretty
much the worst idea I can imagine at
this point right that is a terrible idea
unless you're going to you know actively
take temperature checks at subway
stations unless you're going to have
people take antibody tests before they
before they got on the subway by the way
there's talk about doing this for
traveling on planes right is that you
might have to have a clean bill of
health before you can get on a plane so
you don't infect everybody who is on a
plane but some important things to note
about the removal of lockdown so let's
let's talk about what removal of
lockdown can do and what removal of
lockdown is unlikely to do so what it
can do is it means that you're going to
see in uptick in the economy as people
go out and they shop in a certain amount
of social distancing wearing masks at
grocery stores are still operating
because people still need their
groceries you're gonna see some retail
shops go back to operating you're gonna
see haircut places operating although
people are going to try and space out
when they get their haircuts a little
bit more right I don't think people are
gonna get you're not gonna go to the
nail salon as often ladies and you're
not gonna go get a haircut is often
gentlemen there's just people are going
to space out their behavior the reason I
say that is because people were spacing
out there this this cut I'm gonna give
you a stat that does go to show you that
the American people are responsible this
is an argument in favor of getting rid
of the lockdowns the argument in favor
of getting rid of the lockdowns is that
the amount of social distancing the
amount of social distancing in the
United States was increasing rapidly
before the lock downs happened before
the lock downs HAP
people were already starting to not go
out people were like I've said for my
own family we decided not to go to a
porn party this is like March 6th I
believe was poor him in the in the
United States let's see
poor him poram date 2020 poor him in the
United States was March 10th so March
10th was before the lockdown in Los
Angeles Los Angeles lockdown only began
the following week I remember
March 10th enough said before was the
date when I turned to my family I was
like I don't think we're going to this
porn party I think that we are going to
stay home given what is what is
happening that's that's happening with a
huge number of people Lyman stone is a
political scientist over at American
Enterprise Institute he put out a chart
and it shows state by state how social
distancing preceded the stay at home
orders in virtually every case often by
several weeks I mean the chart basically
looks like here is the here is the date
of the lockdown order and you can see
social distancing starting to the amount
of social the amount of social contact
starting to decline lockdown flat
meaning that people had already started
to lock down and not go out as much and
this makes perfect sense right people
are not stupid they don't want to die
right people want to people want to
socially distance this is what I think
you can trust the American people I've
said this before I think you can trust
the American people I think that the
media right now are not picking they're
going on they're attempting to find
people who are actively militating
against this sort of stuff just so that
they can argue for the lockdowns to
continue as though you can't trust the
American people to do this stuff there's
a CBS News poll today and it shows if
stay at home restrictions were lifted
would you be comfortable going to a bar
or restaurant 29% of people say yes 71%
of people say no get on an airplane 15%
of people say yes 85% of people say no
go to a large event 13% of people say
yes 87% of people say no in other words
most Americans are not going back to
anything remotely resembling normal even
when the lock downs are removed so it's
important to know that when you're
talking about the lock downs and again
that's that's good news in the sense
that Americans are not rushing out to be
irresponsible and it's bad news in the
sense that the economy is just not going
to recover the same way that people seem
to expect it's going to recover once
these lock downs are over by the way we
are seeing this in Germany as well right
german shoppers are not rushing back to
as stores reopen according to Reuters
German consumers are counting their
pennies rather than returning to shop in
large numbers
as source gradually reopened after being
locked down which makes perfect sense
people are losing their jobs people are
losing their income people are saving
instead of spending it's gonna change
all sorts of spending habits in the
United States like really gonna change
seriously the spending habits in the end
the Association habits in the United
States okay we're gonna get to more of
this in just one second we're gonna talk
about how these single factor analysis
being used by some people in the media
and governor's on the left is really
really stupid and backwards and fails to
take into account a lot of really
important factors when you get to that
in just a second first let's talk about
how important your home is to you
particularly at a time like this imagine
getting evicted for non-payment of a
loan that you never took out I mean
forget about all of the financial
troubles that everybody's experiencing
right now think of you own your home
you're making your payment's and
suddenly you get evicted anyway that
actually happened to Deborah it's
happening everywhere it's called home
title theft
the FBI says it's one of the fastest
growing crimes in the country this is
why you should get home title lock your
homes legal title is kept online thieves
do know that they will Forge your
signature on your homes title and then
that's it people will think that they
legally owned your home and then they
will take out loans against your home
and load you up with debt your bank
doesn't cover you your insurance doesn't
cover you the only way I know to avoid
this thing is home title lock go to home
title lock com register your address to
see if you are already a victim and then
use code SAVE for 33 days of protection
to help you get through this crisis
again enter save at home title lock calm
get that 30 days of free protection so
you don't have to shell out any cash
right at the moment when everybody is
short on cash and you can protect your
home any way home title lock calm and
it's a smart thing to do to protect your
property home title lock icon protect
your credit and your property at home
title lock calm okay so New York is
talking about how they are going to ease
this burden right how they're going to
easily come in and obviously well let me
first give you a couple of factors as to
why it's so important to ease this okay
because what you're about to hear is a
bunch of politicians who pretend that
that the economy is not part of real
life and that people's livelihoods and
people's and people's lifestyle and
people's happiness is somehow not even a
remote consideration here by the way it
should be noted that the people's lives
are on the line it's particularly more
true not in the United States than it is
in the United States thank God the
United States
incredibly prosperous country but the UN
is actually estimating that coronavirus
pandemic could push 130 million people
to the brink of starvation it turns out
that a lot of people are very much
reliant on America's economy and that
when America's economy goes down when
the European economy goes down when the
world economy goes down that hundreds of
millions of people could starve
according to CNN famines could hold and
could take hold in about three dozen
countries in a worst-case scenario
according to the executive director of
the World Food Programme 10 of those
countries already have more than a
million people on the verge of
starvation
he cited an economic recession a decline
in a to collapse in oil prices as
factors leading to vast shortages of
food and her swift action to avert
disaster when the economy goes down
people don't eat that is a reality it's
more true outside the United States and
it's true inside the United States but
it's true for American citizens as well
and it's also true that businesses are
going under that support people and by
the way the cut the Congress set up a
series of ridiculous and perverse
incentives with regard to employment in
the Charis Act that they should fix
immediately there were some Republicans
who tried to stop this provision of the
bill and they were mocked for it hey
Bernie Sanders can up said are you
really saying that people are going to
leave their jobs you know late this
month yeah yes because if they don't
have a guarantee on the other that's a
rational decision they don't have a
guarantee on the other end that they
will have a job there's an article at
CNBC today about a woman named Jamie
Black Lewis she says she felt like she
won the lottery after getting two
forgivable loans through the Paycheck
Protection paycheck production program
black Lewis sawed Lee 177,000 and forty
$3,800 loans one for each of the spa's
Jones in Washington State as a lifeline
she could use for payroll and other
business expenses she halted pay for all
the 35 employees at her spas when black
Lewis convened a virtual employee
meeting to explain her good fortune she
expected jubilation and relief that
paychecks would resume in full even
though the staff couldn't work instead
people were angry they were angry
because it turns out that if they were
considered unemployed they could get
more money than if they stayed employed
by her okay you can't set up perverse
incentives because
incentives matter to pretend that people
don't actually use their brains when it
comes to their own economic situation is
idiotic the bulk of funds from these
loans have to go toward payroll salaries
have to remain intact employee headcount
must not decrease businesses have until
June 30th to rehire laid off or
furloughed workers black Lewis was
trying to meet the rules but the anger
came from employees who determined they
would
make more money by collecting
unemployment benefits than their normal
paycheck that of course is a perverse
incentive that's been set up meanwhile
small businesses are being destroyed by
the fact that everybody is scared to
come out of their houses and it's
extending - it has ripple effects
through the economy so even industries
that are not being directly hit like say
the construction industry you're in the
construction industry well that has
nothing to do with you know the
restaurant industry or the travel
industry or the hotel industry right
it's just you building a house the quote
the problem is the person who wants you
to build the house no longer has the
money to pay you to build the house and
so I here's a letter that I just got
from man named Justin he said I'm
listening now to your show talking about
how to help small business survive once
our paycheck protection program money
runs out we will most likely shut down
prior to the shutdown we had a two
million dollar backlog is the direct
result of the government shutdown we
have only four hundred thousand dollars
working process with the majority being
pushed out to deliver in June July in
August of 2020 when the original
schedule had this work due in April
we'll probably be here for eight more
weeks due to the paycheck protection
funding after that our revenue our
revenue stream will be drastically
reduced and we're going to have to shut
down he says our company was founded in
1967 by my grandfather I'm a third
generation owner I've been here since
2007 owner since 2014 we won't recover
the almost 50 people we employ will no
longer have a job many of whom have been
here for 20 plus years so are we going
to pretend that those stories don't
matter that these people don't matter
the reason I ask that question is
because there's been this bizarre notion
I mean really bizarre that if you want
the economy reopened in a responsible
fashion recognizing all of the obstacles
here and the failure of easy answers and
recognizing also that the status quo may
not become the status quo ante right
that the new status quo is different
than the old status quo if you say that
then people suggest that you don't care
about human life andrew Cuomo played
this game yesterday and honestly what he
said is awful so the governor of New
York has been widely feeted by the media
for his brilliant leadership despite the
fact that his state got hit harder than
any state in America and he was late on
the ball andrew Cuomo yesterday he was
asked about people who want to work and
here was his ridiculous sneering answer
how can the Cure be worse than the
illness if the illness is potential
death
the what if the economy failing worse me
death is equals that because the people
those people stuck at home no it doesn't
it doesn't eat with death
economic hardship yes very bad not death
right work go take the job as an
essential worker do it tomorrow right
you're working you're an essential
worker so don't take the job is
essential you can get a job as an
essential worker wouldn't it wouldn't
absolute evil I mean seriously what an
absolute a-hole that what just
unbelievable stop from Andrew Cuomo
there so first of all the the baseline
notion that is the easiest and most
scoundrel and it's the most scoundrel
like take on politics I can imagine is
death is not equal to any of the other
things yes that's true death is not
equal to any of the other things death
is worse than all of the other things
for the individual but for the society
we make these calculations all the time
because that's called policymaking and
responsible policymakers make policy
based on weighing a variety of factors
not one factor if you're wearing one
factor you're a bad politician you're a
bad policymaker everybody understands
this everyone understands this no one's
willing to say it out loud because
they're gutless but everybody
understands that they're gonna have to
make these calculations Andrew Cuomo
pretending I'm saving every life and
okay so I ruin the economy also I just
have a question for Andrew Cuomo why
does he get to decide what an essential
job looks like you know what usually
decides what an essential job looks like
people human beings the economy not
Andrew Cuomo now saying that you are an
essential worker you know I'll give you
an example apparently according to
Andrew Cuomo that reporter is an
essential worker and so I guess that all
the people who are out of jobs you know
working who are working at restaurants
thing just get chops as reporters and if
they want to work thing just get a job
as a reporter they can just go become a
nurse or a doctor today and what in the
world that this is this is a it's just
another version of learn to code right
it's just another version of you're
gonna lose your job and therefore you
should just move into an essential
industry except we decide which
industries are essential you know whose
jobs are essential everyone's jobs are
essential and super
pretend that the job is not essential to
the person or to the economy is to
override both everybody else is free
choice and the interest of the person
who just lost their job their 30 million
of them 30 million of them get a job as
an essential worker and honestly like
what would his Andrew Cuomo's history of
being an essential worker other than
working in government it and and by the
way it like he was just elected to the
position it's not like it is not as
though he has provided some eminent and
objective benefit to the state of New
York through his service that's not the
way that this works essential workers
that even the phrase is is ridiculous on
its face that's not to suggest that
lockdowns weren't necessary and that
there aren't truly essential workers but
I will point out that my job in the
media is far less essential than a
doctor or a nurses job there are
gradations of essential and by the way
I'm not sure that what like why is it
that my job is considered an essential
job right doing a podcast why and and
running a website why is my job
considered an essential job in the same
category as the people who are who are
bringing you your groceries it's
arbitrary and it's ridiculous and it's
silly
the real reason that they say that the
media aren't essential job is because
they don't want to run into a First
Amendment violation is the real reason
that they are doing that but at the same
time they're saying that pastors and
rabbis I guess are not essential job so
it's it's it's all this is all arbitrary
and if it were connected to public
health at this point I'm all in favor of
it but I don't think that it's connected
to public health I think that he is
using as an excuse for his bad public
policy the if I save even one life
routine now he's not even the worst I
mean first of all that that's an
enormous amount of scorn for people who
are losing their livelihoods and you're
seeing in the media too
the attempt to portray everybody who's
protesting in favor of economy reopening
and lockdowns being ended by the
government the attempt to portray those
people as Nazi flag-waving morons and
white supremacists Huffington Post
compared them to the Charlottesville
protesters it's disgusting
those are normal people who want to go
back to work and you know what we live
in a responsible country we live in a
republic and we will have restrictions
on social distancing we will have
restrictions I'm wearing masks those
will continue to be in place but to
pretend that those people's interests
don't matter or that in aggregate the
only interest that matters is a policy
that may or may not save lives because
we even don't know whether the lockdowns
have saved
in the first place I think they probably
saved some at least in the short-term
but we don't know as the lock downs are
relieved whether there's no
counterfactual right we don't know what
would have happened if we did why when
we did X there's just no way to tell
that we don't have a multiple universes
machine or we can tell what the
counterfactual would have been to
pretend that you invariably have the
right answer because you've decided that
it's important that America be Bubble
Boy and that there are no countervailing
interests is just bad public policy
making speaking of bad public policy
making by the way just gonna point out
that aoc continues to just be I've
suggested she has the IQ of a kumquat I
think I'm giving her too much credit I
quote a kumquat it does have a form of
life it does a brain or it doesn't have
like a functioning brain stem or
anything but it does have a form of life
it is animate I am Not sure that she has
an IQ above that of an inanimate object
I mean I'm talking about like the IQ of
a rock now and a plant doesn't really
have a higher IQ than Iraq I suppose but
there's the possibility of some form of
life that like let me put it this way
there is a vacuum between the ears like
an absolute vacuum you could you could
you could create an ion collider in that
head because there's there's nothing
happening up there
here was AOC yesterday explaining that
after coronavirus is over and we end the
lockdowns people should protest and not
go back to work which is like the most
cruel and stupid thing I've ever heard
of course people should go back to work
they should strike what's it say you can
blow out the debt on the basis of future
generations and then pay them to not go
back to work here is AOC being
completely insane I think when we talk
about this idea of reopening society you
know only in America does the president
when the president tweets about
liberation does he mean go back to work
when we you know have this discussion
about going going back or reopening I
think a lot of people should just say no
we're not going back to that we're not
going back to working 70 hour weeks just
so that we could put food on the table
and not even feel any sort of semblance
of security in our lives
yeah homelessness is the solution
probably dramatic unemployment refusal
to go back to work in a time when there
are tens of millions of people who will
freely take the job that you want sad
that reopening
only in America is it considered
reopening to be able to go back to work
really it seems like most people want to
work most people want to work and by the
way if most people don't want to work
then that gives the lie to the basic
idea of universal basic income in the
welfare state which is that if you
create a disincentive to work that
people will continue to work so what she
is saying is of course full-scale idiocy
and it is scorned for workers because
the idea is you're a sucker you're a
sucker if you go to work if you just
listen to a OC she'll pay her salary
having created zero jobs for entire life
she is going to she's going to pay your
salary today and all of this does not
show a great deal of sympathy for
workers who actually need to go feed
their families and this is why it's
important that we actually take into
account all of the costs and benefits of
the policies that we are implementing
right now and by the way even on the
life side of the ledger even on the life
side of the ledger there's good
information that a lot of people are
dying because they are not going into
er's even when they need to go into ers
because they're afraid of coronavirus so
all the heart attacks have basically
disappeared according to physicians
across the country California's hospital
EDS are strangely quiet places these
days according to the LA Times because
people who are having strokes and heart
attack simply are not coming in and
they're not coming in because of
coronavirus so a bunch of people are
dying because they are not getting their
cancer treatments and their heart attack
treatments there are lots of balances to
be weighed here and to pretend that the
balance is easy on either side is to be
a liar and when you get some more of
this in just one second first there are
lots of things in life we look back on
and we think how could I possibly have
gotten this one so wrong
like for example hiring Michael Mills
just bad decisions that you make in your
life well we're always gonna get things
wrong that is life but there are things
we can get right on the first try like
shopping for life insurance this is
where policy genius comes in policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price it could say 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home in auto insurance or
disability insurance it's important to
get these things taken care of now
because god forbid you just don't know
what's gonna happen in the future policy
genius can make it quick they can make
it easy and they can competitively price
the insurance you need all types of
insurance so even if you look back on
the days when you wore a suit suit in
distress you will never be distressed
with life insurance from policy genius
in just a few minutes find your best
price and apply at policy genius
dot-com again that is policy genius.com
policy genius.com
go check them out right now policy
genius.com okay we're gonna get to more
of this in just once I'm going to talk
about President Trump and a couple of
botched media stories president Trump
going after the governor of Georgia
which is a bizarre take by the president
because one second he's tweeting
liberate Virginia and the next he's
telling the governor of Georgia that
he's doing things too soon like seems
like a bit of a mixed message well gets
that in just a second first being locked
inside right now
it requires double the excitement double
the joy double the leftist here's you
get two of these two of them one of them
I activated the invisibility cloak on
actually so here's the other one right
here is one and here is the other just
to show you the full capacity of the
leftist tears tumblr you get two of
those when you become a daily wear
insider plus our all-access remember I'm
not lying to you I am not kidding with
Bernie Sanders now out of the race for
president one tumbler is not enough to
hold all of the leftist years now you
don't believe me that it actually has
the capacity for invisibility you don't
right you think that I am just making
that up
whoa whoa view of the magic daily where
members get many amazing benefits
including the magnificent irreplaceable
singular leftist cheers tumblr you also
get an ad-free website experience access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight op-eds
from hua daily where members also get to
ask us questions during backstage you
get to participate in all access live
that is our brand-new interactive
programming featuring one of the daily
wire our host as we hang out with you
every night from 8 p.m. Eastern to 5 p
or 5 p.m. at Pacific that content is
normally for all access members we've
opened it up to everybody during the
pandemic so again become an insider plus
or all-access member double your tears
with two leftist years tumblr go to
daily wire calm slash subscribe to get
started you get 10% off coupon code
Shapiro's which is a great deal write
10% off that deal and you get two of the
tumblers that's daily wire.com slash
subscribed coupon code shapiro got the
rarest of all beverage vessels x 2
you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
now everybody if they are honest
understands that there are trade-offs to
the lockdown policies and that we don't
actually know the full consequences of
the trade-offs we know pretty well what
the consequences are economically and
that is a complete collapse what we
don't know are the consequences in terms
of the virus we don't know that yet
because we are seeing what happens in
Germany we're gonna have to see what
happens in Sweden we have to see what
happens in countries around the world
which are reopening by the way right
they are reopening in the same way that
Georgia is talking about reopening but
if Georgia does it it's very bad and if
Trump promotes it is very bad apparently
the New York Times is quietly
recognizing that hey public policy
making his trade-offs Peter Baker
writing for the New York Times he says
until there's a vaccine or a cure McCobb
truth is that any plan to begin
restoring public life invariably it
means trading away some lives the
question is how far will leaders go to
keep it to a minimum some of the more
provocative voices on the right say that
with tens of millions of Americans out
of work and business is collapsing some
people must be sacrificed for the
greater good of restoring the economy
quickly too many that sounds unthinkable
but less inflammatory experts and policy
makers also acknowledge there are
enormous cost to keeping so much of the
workforce idle with many of the
unemployed struggling to pay for food
shelter or medical care for other health
challenges so look Helen your attends
even phrases that right so the last part
that if you are a less inflammatory
expert you acknowledge trade-offs that
means that you're good but if you are a
if you are a person stumping for
lockdowns to be ended and you
acknowledge trade-offs that's very bad
so in other words if the New York Times
doesn't like the fact of an AR buyer
named your bad person when this is the
way the media are treating Brian Kemp in
Georgia dana Milbank has an absolutely
absurd column for the Washington Post
today called Georgia leads the race to
become America's number one death
destination okay we know what America's
number one death destination is right
now and it's New York City a taint
Georgia okay but according to Dana
Millbank Governor Brian Kemp is
proposing to offer a new nonstop service
to the great beyond his a bold plan to
turn his state into the place to die
he's doing this even though the state
ranks near last in testing even though
it's not clear Cove in 19 cases are
declining there even knowing we're
probably gonna have to see our cases
continue to go up public health experts
fear coronavirus will burn through
Georgia like nothing has since William
Tecumseh Sherman but Kemp is making a
big gamble gamble his constituents
wouldn't want to swab places with anyone
and the tourists will be dying to get to
Georgia in any class of travel economy
Economy Plus or intensive care I mean oh
like oh this kind of ridiculous
phraseology from dana Milbank oh he's a
very very bad man Brian Kemp he's the
governor of the state you actually think
that he wants his citizens to die I'm
fairly certain that none of the
governor's want people did I they have
to determine what is the best policy for
their states and again a lot of
businesses in Georgia have been told
they can't open up if they meet certain
criteria they don't meet the criteria
and they're not opening up or they feel
like there's not enough of a market for
them to open up right now now President
Trump under heavy media pressure
apparently President Trump according to
CNN President Trump called up the called
up Brian Kemp yesterday and he had told
Brian Kemp that he supported and praised
that move according to a source familiar
with the call which makes sense Trump
has been calling for everybody to open
up sooner the fact is as I read
yesterday from Erick Erickson that the
number of diagnosed cases versus number
of tests in Georgia is in fact declining
that outside of Atlanta which
theoretically could be a hot spot
there's a lot of rural Georgia that
should be opening even treating places
across the state as one unified block is
really really silly but Trump has been
very much urging people to end the
lockdowns as soon as humanly possible
well under pressure obviously yesterday
President Trump decided to undercut Kemp
and then suggest that he was opening up
Georgia too soon which is a way for
Trump to to cover his political rear and
and a move that I think frankly is wrong
I mean if you're gonna delegate the
power so here's what he's done in the
past couple of weeks I have national
control the situational control
governor's now have national control
governors now have control over their
own states stop locking down your states
also Brian Kemp stop doing what you're
doing in ending the lockdown that's a
very inconsistent message obviously I
will note that the media have been
similarly inconsistent they've been
yelling screaming bloody murder of Brian
Kemp Jerrod Palace the governor of
Colorado is a Democrat he also he's
talking about opening up businesses by
May first zero coverage none nada nil
why because Jared Paulson he's a
Democrat anyway here was president from
yesterday undercutting camp I told the
governor of Georgia Brian Kemp that I
disagree strongly with his decision to
open certain facilities which are in
violation of the phase 1 guidelines for
the incredible people of Georgia they're
incredible people I love those people
they are great they've been
strong resolute but at the same time he
must do what he thinks is right I want
him to do what he thinks is right okay
but he's now he's now completely covered
his ass in case things go wrong in
Georgia right by saying well I told them
that if things go bad it's really on him
he can't have it both ways you can't be
like okay well Gretchen Whitmer over in
Michigan open things up right now and if
you keep them closed and it's on you and
then Brian Kemp I want you to not open
things like sums consistency here would
be nice now he does have the medium
ground
I guess the White House has the medium
ground of being able to say that Georgia
doesn't necessarily fit all the criteria
that we laid out but then why is he
tweeting about Michigan which also
doesn't fulfill the criteria he laid out
so it's a lot of inconsistent messaging
from the White House the bottom line is
this governor Kemp is making a decision
the decision I think is based in the
baseline reality that things are not
going to radically change that there is
not going to be a cure in the next
couple of months there is not going to
be any therapeutic that really changes
things dramatically in the near no
future that we can avoid opening up
under these conditions and that people
are gonna be responsible which again I
think it's a good assumption about the
American people I think most Americans
are responsible I think there are
minority of Americans who are morons and
I think that that's why you need the
hotspot tracing to find where those
minority of Americans who are gathering
in large groups and then infecting each
other or infecting each other so we can
help lock that down but overall if you
don't trust the American people I don't
know why you live in a republic I don't
know I think the President Trump did
make a promise yesterday that I don't
know how he's gonna fulfill and I think
that it being realistic with the
American people at this point would be
really a good thing I know the president
Trump wants to Cheerilee and I know that
he wants to make everybody feel better
about what's going on I'm all for
optimism also when president from
yesterday said we're gonna knock out a
second wave I'd like to know how because
I think that the danger here is that you
are setting up expectations that cannot
be met and that's actually leading
people to want to lock down more than is
absolutely necessary here was Trump
yesterday talking about knocking out a
second wave doctor Robert Redfield was
totally misquoted in the media on a
statement about the fall season and the
virus totally misquoted I spoke to him
he said it was ridiculous he was talking
about the flu
and Corona coming together at the same
time and Corona could be just some
little flare-ups it will take care of
we're gonna knock it out we'll knock it
out fast okay I mean I don't know how
that's that's actually going to be the
case and I think that that's promising
too much it's making people feel as
though until they have a guarantee of
security they're not going back to our
deny me meanwhile the media continue to
be irresponsible and how they handle a
lot of this stuff they are not they're
not giving you any sort but very few
there's some of the media doing it
right many in the media are not giving
you any sort of real information and
instead they're playing this ridiculous
game where they tell you the same way
that they accused Trump of happy talk
they participate in a different type of
happy talk which is if Trump would just
provide 1 million tests every moment
then we would all be fine if Trump just
too taking the right actions this
wouldn't be a pandemic if if Governor
Cuomo gets what he wants if Joe Biden is
president then things will be fixed none
of that is true
ok let's accept a reality for what it is
let's accept the fact that public policy
is trade-offs and that it is a
multivariate analysis and let's accept
the fact that we actually don't know
what's going to happen when we open
things up gradually but one thing we do
know is that the American people are a
responsible people they are ok overall
Americans are not going to rush out and
do things that are stupid and endanger
other Americans that is an overall truth
Americans are going to be cautious in
this which is bad for the economy
truthfully but very good for the balance
that has to be struck I trust Americans
and you should trust Americans too if
you live in a free country already time
for some things that I like and then
we'll get to some things that I hate so
things that I like today so yesterday I
played a clip of myself I love me no no
but it was actually just a clip of me
playing violin with my dad playing Ave
Maria the Baku note arrangement and and
my dad actually recorded two pieces
together this one is the meditation from
Thai used by Jules Massenet a sort of a
classic violin piece we put this one up
on Instagram I believe so if you want to
check out the full version you can do
that here is just a little bit a little
taste
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you want to check out the full
version you can head on over to
Instagram we are taking requests then
we're gonna prep another couple of
pieces because people really seem to be
enjoying these at least in the comments
so we will be doing that okay time for a
thing that I hate so the media are
really doing yeoman's work in trying to
tear down Trump here it's it's pretty
it's pretty impressive the fact is that
the that Trump's actions forget about
his words for a second his actions is
the head of a head of the federal
government have basically been right
there is there's very little that that
Democrats have suggested that Trump has
not done this stuff the Democrats are
suggesting that he do that he has not
done his mum is mainly stupid Trump is
actually handled this thing pretty well
from the policy perspective
he really has but that is not stopping
the media from basically taking the word
of anyone who wants to say a mean thing
about from so let's take an example the
New York Times had a piece yesterday is
called vaccine chief says he was removed
after questioning drug that Trump
promoted the first known u.s. death from
the illness came in early february in
california and according to this vaccine
expert is the New York Times the doctor
who led the federal agency involved in
developing a corona virus vaccine said
on Wednesday he was removed from his
post after he pressed for rigorous
testing of hydroxychloroquine an
anti-malaria drug embraced by President
Trump as a corona virus treatment and
that the administration has put politics
and cronyism ahead of science dr. Rick
bright was abruptly dismissed this week
as director of the Department of Health
and Human Services biomedical Advanced
Research and Development Authority or
Barda and removed as the deputy
assistant secretary for preparedness and
response he was given a narrower job at
the National Institutes of Health so he
wasn't really fired he continued to have
his job inside the federal government at
the NIH in a scoring statement
dr. bright assailed the leadership at
the health department saying he was
pressured to direct money toward
hydroxychloroquine one of these several
potentially dangerous drugs promoted by
those with political connections and
repeatedly described by the President as
seneschal game-changer in the fight
against the virus he said in a statement
I believe this transfer was in response
to my insistence that the government
invests the billions of dollars
allocated by Congress to address covin
19 into safe and scientifically vetted
solutions and not in drugs vaccines or
other technologies that lack scientific
merit I'm speaking out because to combat
this deadly virus science not politics
or cronyism has to lead the way and then
the New York Times just reports as
though this guy is telling the absolute
100% truth because Trump was pumping up
hydroxychloroquine so it must be that
dr. bright that dr. bright is telling
truth and the reason he was fired was
over a hydroxychloroquine right and the
media asked Trump about dr. bright like
repeatedly Jim Acosta and ladies find
you a man who loves you like Jim Acosta
loves himself some Jim Acosta Jim Acosta
on CNN he reported that this fellow dr.
Rick bright that he was a casualty of
Trump's war on science war on science
the guy presents like five doctors at
every press conference but don't worry
trump is fighting a war on science here
is Jim Acosta being Jim Acosta which is
to say a swirlie of the human being he
sounds like he's the casualty Anderson
of the president's war on scientists
were on science in the administration
dr. bright is going to file a
whistleblower complaint he is protesting
his removal from his position leading
that agency that is charged with vaccine
development he was working on a vaccine
for the corona virus when he was
abruptly pulled out of his position he
had been clashing with top officials at
Health and Human Services this tendency
on the part of the president other
administration officials to show
preference for treatments like
hydroxychloroquine when the science is
just not even settled on that and there
are studies showing it doesn't work okay
so this is them just parroting this
right now there's only one problem
there's only one problem
Politico actually reported on what
happened with bright and ain't bright
story according to Politico the abrupt
elster of a top vaccine expert at HHS
has split officials luceat is either a
boon for the nation's Kovan 19 response
or the latest indication of a
dysfunctional health department Rick
bright the director of the biomedical
Advanced Research and Development
Authority was transferred to a new more
narrow role at the NIH this week
according to an HHS spokesperson the
move was more than a year in the making
he wasn't dismissed over
hydroxychloroquine the move was over a
year in the making for a year he'd been
conflicting with other health officials
bright had clashed with
Department leaders about his decisions
and the scope of his authority but came
abruptly said five current and former
HHS officials one person familiar with
the situation said bright was frozen out
of his email and learned about the
reassignment only when his name was
removed from the Barda website this
weekend as of Tuesday bright had not
accepted the reassignment to NIH or he
was tapped to work on efforts to deploy
point-of-care covin 19 at testing bright
told the New York Times in a statement
just repeated just verbatim by the New
York Times that he was fired over
hydroxychloroquine but an official says
if Wright opposed hydroxychloroquine he
certainly didn't make that clear from
his emails quite the opposite three
people with knowledge of HHS's recent
acquisition of tens of millions of doses
of a variety of drugs said bright had
supported the acquisitions in internal
communications with one official saying
that bright praised the move as a win
for the health department as part of an
email exchange first reported but first
reported by Reuters that last week
although brights message was not
publicly reported in a statement late
Wednesday and HHS official a directly
linked brights decision to the health
department's acquisition of the malaria
drugs spokesperson Caitlyn Oakley said
as it relates to chloroquine it was dr.
bright who requested an emergency use
authorization from the FDA for donations
of chloroquine that Bayer and Sandoz
recently made strategic national
stockpile for use on Kovan 19 patient
the EU a is what made the donated
product available for use in combating
kovin 19 and then brighten respond to
multiple requests for comments on
Tuesday and Wednesday after the Health
Department fought back against him
bright said he will ask the HHS's
Inspector General to investigate the
manner in which the administration has
politicized the work and has pressured
me and other conscience as scientists to
fund companies with political
connections that lack scientific merit
so Trump was asked about all this and
Trump being Trump proceeded to just slam
this guy directly into the ground he was
from slamming this supposed expert
vaccine head gifts what do you know him
have you studied him have you reported
on him you said his gifts his gifts I
mean but they can't hit 150 great gifts
I mean okay Trump Trump you know ripping
into the guy personally if you don't
know the story then don't say you know
the story you should say this is an
internal HHS matter but then he should
refer it over to a czar or the secretary
to explain the Disgaea appears he lives
in the New York Times right that's what
it looks like it looks like he went to
the New York Times and said I was fired
pulled for political reasons because I
opposed the president's favorite cure
this hydroxychloroquine thing and then
that wasn't why he was fired he was in
conflict with people for a year and then
anytime somebody just gives a statement
to the New York Times saying that the
real reason I was fired is because Trump
is a nefarious bad man then it's
apparently totally when we take them at
their face value it's just it's absurd I
mean the media do such a crappy job it's
it's truly incredible it's truly
incredible so you know when we when we
look at the media's coverage of this
thing and then we look at Trump's
approval rating recognize that part of
that is because Trump says things a
large part of that is not because of
Trump a large part of that is because
the media spend every waking minute
attempting to demonstrate to the
American public that Trump is corrupt
and evil the reality is that they're
willing to stretch anything into a story
that paints Trump this way and it really
is awful it really is awful Judge Trump
on the merits of his actual response
don't judge him based on the false
reports being made by the media all
right we'll be back a little bit later
to two additional hours of content
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike pore Amina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2020 the UN is predicting 130
million people around the world might
die not because of coronavirus but
because of the economic shutdowns
associated with coronavirus is it still
all worth it to save just one life
Governor Cuomo the new numbers expose a
fundamental moral error on the left
that's been around a lot longer than
coronavirus then failed Georgia
gubernatorial candidate Stacey Abrams
begins to openly campaign to be Joe
Biden's running mate Alec Baldwin
inadvertently reveals some spiritual
truths about Warren teen and finally the
mailbag check it out on the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]